With all the under the hood stuff out of the way,
let's take a look at what the actual DNA
of an Unreal game looks like
and how we can best use it to build our games.
As mentioned previously, UObject is the base class
for all UE4 types,
including all assets inside the content browser.
They have no physical representation in the world
and they have no built in tick functionality.
As they've got no concept of the world,
they have no ability to update the frame.
They must be given an outer.
This is the object that this object resides in.
If one is not given an outer,
it's put inside the transient package,
which is the topmost package used
for storing temporary objects, which should not be saved.
Objects can support networking,
but they do not come with it set about the box.
If networking is required,
perhaps reconsider whether or not UObject
is the right solution
for your current technical requirement.
As an example of a UObject,
we have the UExplosionData asset,
which is used to define properties regarding an explosion.
Actor extends directly off of UObject
and is usually accompanied by a scene component
as its route, giving it a physical representation
in the scene.
For example, consider an exploding barrel.
This would be an actor consisting of smaller discrete
pieces of functionality and a physical representation
through some flavor of mesh.
Actors do have networking support by default,
giving us access to RPCs like we discussed earlier,
as well as standard variable replication.
They're exceptionally well suited
to a component based architecture,
as opposed to a giant monolithic class.
So at this time, consider the following.
If my current technical design requires
either networking or ticking,
go with actors and components.
If you don't require either,
consider using the UObject.
Actor components allow us to roll functionality
into a single class.
They require an actor to exist
because they cannot simply exist in the world.
They're designed to be part of an actor.
And they're excellent when used in conjunction
with Blueprint to expose their parameters
to design with sensible UProperty use.
So as an example,
we can add an explosion component
to our exploding barrel actor
and keep the actor class completely unpolluted.
If another actor in our game
requires some kind of explosion functionality,
we can simply add the component to that class as well,
without having to duplicate anything.
We can also add UProperties to the explosion component
to allow design to plug in an explosion data asset
in as a field, letting them balance
and tweak the functionality separately.
Actor components are not particularly ideal
for networked functionality,
as dormancy can only be set on an actor level,
as opposed to a component level.
A dormant actor will send all of its components dormant
as well, so we may end up with erroneous
or unacceptable behavior as the project grows.
A scene component extends off of actor component
with the benefit of providing
a physical representation in the scene.
They can be attached to other scene components
as well as bones and sockets.
And they can also be used
to detect collisions and overlaps.
It's the scene component that gives a base actor
its physical representation in the scene.
An actor itself has got no intrinsic transform,
but it does have a root component,
just simple scene component
giving us our scene representation.